okay wait a minute I think I'm getting a
call here who's that oh thank God thank
God I'm not too late
Conan Conan hi how are you or you yell
Conan it's it's this is great it's Joel
McHale everybody Joel how are you do you
have all your medication Conan what are
you talking about Medicare I don't I'm
fine one I don't I don't why you asked
me about medications and why are you
talking so loud just calm down I I look
I'm just doing my part as a celebrity to
check up on some of my very good friends
who are probably in a high-risk group
because of their advanced advanced age
and so you know our president he said we
have to we have to take care of our
seniors okay so if there's anything that
you need Conan anything like soft food a
bag of orders candies an hour to an
adult paper do you know I'm not get into
the diaper I can help you get it I don't
think I'm that much older than you yeah
okay you still got it you you read way
way older and I don't think there's
anybody that disputes that now so if you
are having trouble can you
Coenen if you're having trouble put a
piece of red paper in your window okay
just Walker on over there put that in
there and someone younger in their 50s
will come and help you all right well
Joel I think this is misguided but thank
you for your service what service what I
didn't ask you for what you've done the
greatest war was fought by the greatest
generation and that did not fight in
World War two thank you for what you've
done now I'm gonna play some Glenn
Miller music for you so maybe you can
take your third nap okay all right thank
you for checking in on me Joel McHale
derp derp derp derp derp derp dee dee
deee deee daaah this takes you back to
graduate school huh dddd dddd dddd